Thank you for coming today to this masturbatory
display of political theater.
Yup.
Alright, who can ask the stupidest question?
What exactly is Facebook?
Anybody bring props?
I believe the constitution generally applies
to government.
Yeah!
I love a certain kind of chocolate.
Relevant.
Your user agreement sucks.
Your budget sucks!
Do you have any idea how many of your users
actually read the terms of service?
Probably more than the amount of congressmen
who read the budgets they pass.
And even if they read it they may not understand
it?
No sh*t.
I'm a lawyer, I have no idea what that means.
But I bet you still vote for it.
Mumbles.
How many apps there?
Is there an alternative to Facebook in the
private sector?
The rest of the internet?
Second rate Wilford Brimley, go!
You are hurting people.
You're bombing countries.
Congressman meat sweat, go!
Congress is good at two things, doing nothing
and over reacting.
Oh and spending, there's three things.
Diane what should Facebook do?
Take millions of Americans' personal information
without their knowledge.
Jesus I hate this place.
The NSA already does that.
That's alarming.
But it happened!
Are you angry about that?
Yes!
You're upset about this, we' re upset about
this.
Are you?
Pretty obvious to me that someone is uh listening
to the audio on our phones.
You voted for that, is no one reading any
of the bills at all?
Small head, big shirt, go!
My name's Mark Wayne Mullin and feel free
to use that name.
Small head, big shirt.
How do I keep that from happening, is there
settings within the app that I need to go to
to set to block all that?
Do you set your shirt for medium?
I just googled, I just put on your website
Andrew Kinzinger, and he looks a lot like me.
To be fair, you look like every quarterback
who peaked in high school.
You are tracking everyone.
No you're tracking everyone!
Low rent meatloaf!
I don't want to be having information on me.
Yeah it's creepy.
Chappaquiddick junior!
We've seen that with a foreign actor.
Cumberbatch?
Budget Matlock!
I'm a little disappointed in this hearing
today.
I agree.
What do we tell our constituents given what's
happened here.
I think you should just apologize.
Yeah, you know what let me, let me just announce
I will not be seeking reelection next term.
Do you believe you're more responsible with
millions of Americans' personal data
than the federal government would be?
Yes?